لذلك دعونا نبدأ بالحوثيين والسعوديين الذين
يحاولون التوسط في
وقف إطلاق النار الدائم، هناك مطالب الحوثيين برفع
الحصار بالكامل،
فتح المطار المطارات والموانئ
ودفع الرواتب، هل سيحصلون على ما
يريدون من السعوديين من أجل
دفع هذا الأمر إلى الأمام  اه حسنًا بيكي، كما
أشرت بالفعل، يبدو أن الأخبار الجيدة
تتوالى وآمل أن يستمروا في
القيام بذلك، لقد تم سؤالي
بانتظام أه هل هذه نهاية الحرب
أم الإجابة المختصرة هي أنها
البداية كما نأمل أه  في النهاية،
هذه بالتأكيد ممارسة لبناء الثقة، حيث
بدأت المفاوضات في وقت مبكر من عام 2018،
ولكن بالتأكيد، كما أشرت في
المقدمة، ساعد التقارب بين
إيران والمملكة العربية السعودية حقًا في
تسريع هاتين
القوتين العظميين الإقليميتين في الشرق الأوسط.
ساعد حقًا في تسريع
عملية تبادل الأسرى هذه، ونأمل إذا سارت الأمور على
ما يرام، فستبدأ عملية التبادل في اليوم الثالث عشر
وسيعود جميع السجناء البالغ عددهم 887 إلى منازلهم في الوقت المناسب لمدة
ثمانية أعوام، حسنًا، سيكون هذا شيئًا من
هذه الحرب بالوكالة ودعونا نطلق عليها أن
هذا الصراع في اليمن هو مجرد صراع
جيد جدًا ومثال فظيع ولكنه جيد
للصراعات بالوكالة التي
تدور رحاها الآن، وكما تعلم في وقت ما
عبر هذه المنطقة، فإن التنافس الإقليمي
يسميه البعض التنافس الديني ولكن دعنا
نسميه التنافس الإقليمي بين السعودية
وإيران، لقد كان حقًا نوعًا من
العمود الفقري  في ظل الكثير من الفوضى
والصراع الذي رأيناه في جميع أنحاء هذه
المنطقة،
ماذا تخبرنا المملكة العربية السعودية عندما تجلس إلى
طاولة المفاوضات مع إيران حول ما
يحدث في هذه المنطقة لأن هذه
حقًا منطقة في منطقة أريد أن أقولها
ليست حالة أسراب ولكن عند
نقطة انعطاف بالتأكيد أوه
أولا وقبل كل شيء من المهم الإشارة إلى
أن تبادل الأسرى وبسط
حقيقة الحقيقة هو صفقة
بين الحكومة
اليمنية الشرعية وخراطيم ما  السعوديون
والإيرانيون يفعلون وكذلك عمان
والإمارات العربية المتحدة يلعبون
دور الضامنين ويضعون
ثقلهم وراء هذه الصفقات ولكن إذا
رجعنا إلى العاشر أه أبريل أه
نحن بعد العاشر من مارس آسف عندما  تم
الإعلان عن اتفاق بكين
مصدر سعودي رفيع المستوى جلس مع
عدد من الصحفيين وأوضح ودخل
في القليل من التفاصيل
الاتفاق يتضمن
التزام متبادل بعدم الاعتداء أو
دعم أطراف أخرى أه في
العدوان على أي أه أي من الاثنين
دول السعودية وإيران لذلك
تطور مهم جداً أه
وطبعاً بينما الإيرانيون لن
يعترفوا أبداً ربما لأسباب قانونية أنهم
يدعمون الحوثيين أو
يدعمون أو يزودون الحوثيين
بالسلاح ما نراه اليوم هو
بالتأكيد علامة على أن إيران تحمل
ثقل قليلاً على الأقل
قليلاً مع الحوثيين ولكن كما
قلت في البداية، فإن الاتفاق
بين الحكومة اليمنية
والحوثيين لنكن واضحين تماماً، الإيرانيون
هناك سلوك خبيث
للوكلاء الإيرانيين حولهم.  هذه المنطقة حقيقية
أه كانت كذلك منذ سنوات،
ومع ذلك يمكننا مناقشة كيف
تعرف مدى تحالف حركة الحوثيين
مع إيران، لقد رأينا بالتأكيد
دعمًا لجهات فاعلة أخرى حول هذه
المنطقة، وليس أقلها حزب الله على سبيل المثال
في لبنان وحزب الله في  سوريا، لذا
دعونا نتراجع للحظة
ونفكر في الفرص المتاحة
إذا كان هذا التوبيخ الذي تعرفونه ينطبق
على هذه المنطقة الأوسع، وأنا أتطلع إلى
خارج المملكة العربية السعودية وخارج
اليمن وأتحدث عن العراق ولبنان
وسوريا على سبيل المثال، حسنًا، انظر إلى مجرد
حقيقة أنه تم الاتفاق الآن على عودة العلاقات الدبلوماسية.
مجرد حقيقة أن
السعوديين والإيرانيين يمكنهم الآن الجلوس
والتحدث معًا. لست متأكدًا مما إذا كان
السيناريو الأكثر تفاؤلاً هو أننا سنرى
انسحابًا إيرانيًا كاملاً من
البلدان التي ذكرتها منها.  العراق أو
سوريا أو لبنان، حيث يوجد حزب الله
متجذرًا بعمق منذ عام 1982.
حسنًا، لن يحدث هذا ولكن
ما سيحدث الآن هو أن
القوتين الرئيسيتين في المنطقة يمكن أن تجلسا
معًا وتتحدثا، وهذا يمكن أن يساعد في تخفيف
التصعيد.  المساعدة في تحقيق
حلول معقولة والأهم من ذلك
تقليل اهتمام
وتظلم أه الناس في هذه
البلدان. ​​لدى اليمن الكثير لتفوز به كونها
جارة لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بمجرد التوصل إلى
اتفاق سلام يتم التوصل إلى اتفاق سلام دائم.  من
المؤكد أنها ستبدأ في
جني بعض المساعدة الاقتصادية والتنموية
من دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وفي قلب
هذا نحن نقترب منك وأنت تعلم أن
المملكة سترتدي هذا على جعبتها
لمصالحها الاقتصادية ونحن
نشهد تحركًا من نوع ما كما تعلمون
سياسة خارجية قوية هي نوع من
استعراض العضلات في السياسة الخارجية
لسياسة الدبلوماسية عبر
هذه المنطقة من هنا في UA
والتي تخدم المصالح الاقتصادية أيضًا،
ما الذي
يمكن
سماعه أو ضمان فشل هذه
الصفقة بين السعوديين والإيرانيين
ما الذي يتعين على طهران أو المملكة
فعله
بشكل فعال أه
لرؤية هذا على أنه فشل، أعني أنك
تعرف ما هو احتمال
عدم نجاح هذا، أعتقد أن هذا ما أقوله
حسنًا، انظر هناك دائمًا احتمال
عدم نجاحه  عملاً ومن الناحية الفنية،
هناك ثلاثة سيناريوهات يمكن أن
تحدث، الأكثر تشاؤمًا هو أن نبقى
حيث نحن وأنتم، كالمملكة العربية
السعودية ودول أخرى في المنطقة،
أمضينا 40 عامًا في التعامل مع
هذا النظام ومنتجاته الثانوية
وأنتم.  أعلم أن الدفاعات مرتفعة
ولا أعتقد كما قلنا في المرة الماضية أنه لن
يرمش أحد خلال هذه
الفترة، فنحن واضحون للغاية بشأن
ما هو معرض للخطر هنا ولكن إذا لم
ينجح الأمر، فسنعود إلى
الوضع  الوضع الراهن وأنت تعلم أننا
نتطور وننمو على الرغم من أن
ما سيكون مخزيًا هو ضياع
الفرصة وبالطبع كانت إيران
ستزعج قوة عظمى كبرى في
العالم وهي الصين التي هي
الضامن والوسيط في هذا وأنت
تعلم  التزمت الصين
باستثمارات بقيمة 300 مليار دولار في
إيران على مدار الـ 25 عامًا القادمة، ولا
أعتقد أن الإيرانيين يريدون الابتعاد
عنها على الرغم من أنهم فعلوا
أشياء غير معقولة في الماضي، وهو
السيناريو الأكثر تفاؤلاً الذي تحدثنا عنه
سابقًا.  أننا نصحو ذات يوم وتحل
كل هذه القضايا
وتقرر إيران الانسحاب أعتقد
أن السيناريو الأكثر واقعية هو
ما يحدث الآن هو إعادة
العلاقات الدبلوماسية دعم
الحكومات الشرعية على الأرض
دعم محادثات السلام بين
الأطراف المتحاربة أه  في ميانمار لأن هذا
اتفاق يجب أن يتم بينهما
حتى يكون مستدامًا